de l'eau de l'eau la terre la vie
irradiéanta poonia mon Providence nom
son TER les blé
comam donne un nom rare fol
ou sinon ça combava donne ài le nom
combava pour son goût en plus dans mon
assett mangé de l'eau la terre la
vie merci retrouve à nous là côté de l'
de l' le titre de dernier livre pourquoi
on a fait le choix de ce thème là fait
surtout c'était un livre sans texte
commfine fait un note avant et queelle a
bien marché me dit bah à cause pas
suivre quelque chose sans parole sans
l'écriture et c'est comme ça que nous
démarre depuis un robinet et nous
suivent de l'eau quand il coule et quand
il rentent sous la terre et là nous
s'imagine que ça se passe par en bas
alors les étonnant pour quelqu'un comme
vous qui aime les mots de faire le choix
d'un livre sans texte oui et en raison
de M on l' pas fait rien dans livre là
mais dit ben si c'est pas à cause d'un
point de texte dedans que les histoires
il faut pas au réfléchir et comme a
travaillévec CLIRE Boval sur la mise en
scène le storyboard et tout ça là ben il
faut décrire case par case que ça
espacee décrire l'action comme si vous
voulez dans un cinéma ou un film Le que
ça le caméra il voit que ça
décrit dans les images le rythme tout ça
là donc c'est un gros travail et en
raison oui mais mettent pas le mot en
avant mais m permet de raconte ensemble
propre mot et là c'est un notre démarche
pourquoi on fait ce choix de laisser
libre cours du texte au lecteur
finalement parce qu'en fait M rend
compte que voilà il fait 20 ans il fait
ce métier là et arrivve à l'URE de Mo
est toujours en train de bataille sur ah
il faut écrire comme ça pas comme ça
nous g paser en créole dis bon ok la
langue il pose problème la langue écrit
pose problème et ben m écrit pas àut
cause et à travers ça mais permettre un
public beaucoup plus large de rentre
dans le livre parce que par exemple de
moun il di Mo ah bon Marme il commence
lire des fois il aime pas trop bon livre
mais là le livre sans texte les
gaillards il rentre dedans ou bien
admoun il travaille avec ça sur un plan
plutôt médical comme un l'outil pour
faire travailler la
[Musique]
mémoire
nous il fait 20 ans que on est dans le
métier finalement que ça pousse à écrire
au début mon mon Mar mon point de départ
est là en fait tout ce travail là depuis
20 ans crois que S a un force la pousse
à moi jusqu'à là c'est mon premier
marmaille d'abord et si lumière c'est
mon deuxè marma et justement a une
grande part de littérature consacré aux
enfants oui ça important pour est
important parce moiême qu Mar pas un bon
peu de Liv autour de moi et en plus que
ça n'avait point de livre CRÉO et du
coup c'est comme ça que moi commence
avec mon premiers histoires pour marma
ticuya que la sortte en 2009 et tigouya
a gagné un succès extraordinaire parce
que quand il arrive on n point de
histoires pour marmaille en créole et on
na point d' histoirc sur la Réunion
tigouya a amène à moi d'autres choses et
jusqu'à l'heure moi elle est encore
là-dedans et comment on explique
attachement justement à transmettre
notre langue moi il comprends que nous
les juste de passage et sur ce passage
là il faut nous laisser un trace donc
peut-être mon bon livre reste après moi
et que de me va C dessus de me va
attraper et il pense que l' important
nous laisse quelque chose de positif sur
sur notre
[Musique]
Chemino enfants la TER
là
dooarine
papa
Doo mon
Baba on fait pas que des livres non on a
aussi bon peu fonker ou les musiciens
que ça ira à haut dans tout ça comment
on retrouve à haut dans tout ça la
musique qui tourne en Pia dans la case
matin jusqu'au soir très tard euh mon
bibliothèque est très grand on a besoin
d'aller voir mon spectacle mais nourrir
à moins de tout ça et M mettre en
partage mon ban de travail c'està-dire
que mon ban de texte maisime bien qu'on
a un autre Moon il vient pour illustrer
pour mettre en images pour mettre en
musique et c'est comme ça mes partages s
les pas mon tout seul dans mon travail
dans mon coin pas fait ça c'est le
partage merci
beaucoup